hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my no spoilers guardians of the
galaxy to review and I'll rank all my
favorite Marvel films after guardians to
at the end of the video if you're new to
the channel there's a spider-man
action-figure giveaway going on all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video so there's
something really special about this film
is the James Gunn wanted to capture the
magic of the first film without
replicating every last thing but there's
this famous Joss Whedon quote when he
got to the second Avengers film and they
were like hey how are you gonna top the
schwarmann moment and he said sometimes
the only way to win is to not try so it
was like okay we're going to do really
awesome things but we're not going to do
an exact same version of the schwarmann
moment so that's kind of the idea with
guardians to is that you capture all the
things that made that first film amazing
and fresh without recycling every single
plot beat and joke so the plot itself
actually becomes one of the least
important things about the movie now
there is a plot it spends more time
capitalizing on the magic of the
characters in what's going on inside
their heads and what's going on with
their relationships so like guardians of
the galaxy one was already the most
colorful most musical film that Marvel
had ever made probably one of the best
creative endeavors that they had there
are other Marvel films that I do like
more than the first guardians film but
is definitely the most magical film in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe before
guardians 2 so the music is always
amazing as expected the visual color
palette has expanded so it's even more
mind-bending they even mastered a
version of the film and HDR so if you
have an HDR Dolby movie theater nearby
you kind of have to check on the web to
find out where they are go see it in HDR
because those princes of films just pop
so much more it looks so much more
beautiful but the film itself looks that
much more beautiful than any of the
other Marvel films that's often the
criticism of a lot of the early phase 1
phase 2 films but you can see James
Gunn's influence on the other Marvel
movies that are coming in phase 3 look
at the Thor Ragnarok trailer look how
much more colorful that film looks than
the other Thor films you look at the
colors pop and spider-man homecoming so
you're starting to see the influence of
James Gunn trickle down to the other
Marvel films things have gone so well
with the guardians franchise
but you do wonder if it could ever
stumble and there are a couple jokes
that go on a little too long in the film
very minor complaints is that they do
mind the film a lot for comedy the
villains are mostly used for a comedy in
some of the plot elements relative to
them are a little thin like I said the
plot is probably the least important
thing about the movie that's really
mostly in service of the heroes
character's journey so there are a lot
more heroes that they focus on in this
movie you go way deeper into everyone in
yondu not baby Groot steals the show so
everybody sees the way they market baby
Groot you're like okay very clearly
there's going to be some big Groot twist
they want to sell a bunch of Groot toys
no it is a yondu's performance Michael
Rooker that completely steals the show
in this movie in suddenly after seeing
it I started to understand why James
Gunn makes fun of him so openly I'm
going to play this clip of him at the
premiere and just think about it this
way the better Michael Rooker's
performances in James Gunn's movies the
more he makes fun of them so watch what
he says about him in this I take it back
there I don't want to do with Michael
Rooker anymore he's going to say
something stupid it's going to embarrass
me like he's been embarrassing you know
one of the great things about guardians
of galaxy vol 2 is it's a gift for
people all over the world
but I also consider it a charity for
Michael Rooker because otherwise how is
he going to ever make a dime if he
doesn't have my movies act and that's
how he makes his living so true isn't
that totally crazy you can see the love
that James Gunn has for Michael Rooker
and that he said on the commentary for
the first guardians film that every time
Michael Rooker has been in one of his
movies he's never let him down but the
crazy thing is that he was never
originally supposed to be in the first
guardians film yondu was a character
that he created really late in the game
specifically for Michael Rooker he's
like I'm going to create a role for my
friend Michael Rooker and that's going
to be yondu and he said he was really
happy that Marvel let him be in the film
because he hadn't done really big movies
like guardians of the galaxy before he
signed on for that a couple years ago so
I think that originally Marvel was a
little skeptical about the idea of the
yondu characters the craziness of the
thin he's like oh maybe this wouldn't
work so we get to the second movie and
they find out that the first one works
so
well they're like okay be as crazy as
you want so we finally get full-blown
comic-book yondu and of all the
characters stories in the movie ego the
Living Planet is an amazing character I
was so happy to see him Kurt Russell is
amazing but yondu's story is the most
interesting one during the movie
so you'll see he has the best story he
has the best relationship with Peter
quill I felt like the relationship
between Peter quill and ego was
interesting but it wasn't quite as
compelling as his relationship with
yondu but I think that's kind of the
idea
yondu is the surrogate father that
raised him ego the Living Planet is the
one that just rolls up and says I'm your
father Peter the one that you haven't
seen for the last 20 plus years there
were a couple core characters on the
guardians team from the first film that
were underserved in the first movie that
they totally correct in this one Gamora
and nebula are amazing so Gamora is like
a main guardians character so you expect
her to get a lot of story she was kind
of underserved in the first film I think
a lot of her scenes just hit the cutting
room floor so she just didn't have quite
as much to do they totally fix that and
even though there's this romantic
element they've been hyping up between
her and Peter quill her biggest
relationship in the film is with her
sister nebula that's way more
interesting to what's going on with her
and Peter quill and Karen Gillan is
amazing but she is at both times
terrifying and adorable in this movie
and she was definitely underserved in
that first movie she was just the
jealous henchman sisters they cut her
hand off Empire Strikes Back style to
escape she just totally bailed during
the first movie but she totally brings
it in this Gamora is a badass character
but nebula was way more fun way more
hardcore in this movie in baby Groot so
a lot of people might be turned off by
how twee he is okay very clearly he's
meant to be the audience surrogate for
little kids in the movie just a dumb
person who's trying to help out he's not
the Groot from the first film so we can
talk more about the mechanics of that
when I post my spoilery video but other
new characters mantas so very clearly
the biggest new character she's the
reason why Adam warlock is not in the
film because James Gunn didn't want to
take focus away from her and he was
introducing so many new characters
already so I loved the character from
the comics Tom Clemente F did a really
good job with her I feel like there are
a couple of jokes that just don't quite
and with her and just like ego they do a
couple really big things in the movie
they're important characters but I feel
like they'll get more character
development when we get to the next
movie is like you introduce a new
character but you really don't go super
deep into them until the second movie
that they're in that's kind of what
happened with the main guardians
characters you meet all them in the
first film you learn a little bit about
them
this second film explores them in a much
deeper context and I will confirm
talking about post-credit scenes there
are a bunch of them and without getting
into spoilers one of them services the
yondu character in a really interesting
way it makes you wonder how much bigger
he's going to be in the next film so
whatever you do make sure you stay
through the end of the film and watch
the credits because during the movie
there are a couple characters that are
introduced and it's probably the biggest
comic book Easter Egg that Marvel has
ever done in any of their films on par
with Nick Fury coming to recruit Tony
Stark at the end of that first Iron Man
film that's how big a deal it was but
because it's a comic book Easter egg I
wonder how many people are going to miss
it's significant so don't worry I will
do a post credit scene video where I
explain what's going on but like my
other spoilery videos those won't post
till after the film comes out everywhere
so don't worry there's plenty of time to
talk about specific post credits scene
stuff so if you do get a chance to see
the movie before everyone else please
don't post spoilers in the comments but
of all the Marvel directors and Phase
three so far James Gunn and the Russos
are probably the biggest comic book fans
that they have directing movies so they
have the most comic book II moments in
their films so just be sure to watch the
film carefully or see it a couple times
if you have to I feel like a lot of the
films in the Marvel Universe I judge on
their rewatch ability probably the most
important thing for some of you ranking
my favorite Marvel films after watching
guardians of the galaxy - so sometimes
this list will changed throughout the
year but now it's Captain America Winter
Soldier guardians - and guardians 1 are
relatively even but I'll give the edge
to guardians 2 for the additional
spectacle that it was able to pull off
then civil wars in the first Avengers
film so once you do get a chance to see
it let me know what your top 5 favorite
Marvel films are in the comments
speaking of which I feel like there's a
benchmark that nobody else is going to
hit this summer
and that's Logan in terms of
emotionality so guardians of the galaxy
2 is Marvel's most emotional film but if
not quite as as emotional as Logan
nothing else is going to touch that this
year I feel like in terms of spectacle
Thor Ragnarok is going to take the crown
now that's not talking about Star Wars
or some of the other films I'm just
talking about the Marvel film so
guardians of the galaxy - brings the
emotion spider-man homecoming brings the
heart in Thor Ragnarok brings that grand
spectacle just to give you guys a little
tease for things to come they're saying
that they have the biggest action
set-pieces they've ever done in any
Marvel film including both Avengers
films inside Thor Ragnarok so we'll let
you wonder what that is just remember
that they have some of the most powerful
characters in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in that movie so what's going
to happen later today is they're
dropping new spider-man Home Coming
promos I'll do a video for that we got a
better look at our man's ultimate Iron
Man suit that he's going to be wearing
during the film and leave all your
requests for Marvel videos in the
comments below but congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Blake
Anderson please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details but you can click
here for brand-new black panther the
footage breakdown and you can click here
for brand news justice league thank you
so much for watching let's high-five
see you guys in the next video
you